French unions wanted a big turnout for
Thursday's Nationwide protests to
emphasize the strength of opposition to
pension reform they got their wish this
was Central Paris
most French people accept the pension
system needs reforming but more than 70
percent according to the polls are
opposed to Emmanuel macron's plan to
raise the retirement age to 64. when you
look at the amount of the BNP the amount
of shareholders of the profits made by
the shareholders and the amount of
wealth that is created in the country
today we are saying we should use a bit
more of that wealth to fund decent
pensions for all workers both in public
and private sector rather than
continuously enriching those who are
only The Riches of society the French
president on a visit to Spain says
France can't afford to keep things as
they are
in countries where people live longer
where we have created strong and fair
welfare system which rely on equality
between Generations at moments where
there are fewer and fewer people who are
economically active and more and more
who are retired if you want a pact
between generations to be fair this
reform needs to be carried out
train drivers teachers and staff at
refineries as well as public transport
workers were among those who walked off
their jobs
his biggest unions have joined forces
it's unusual they're not so United these
days and the unions are themselves are
not as powerful as they once were but
they hope that this protest will expand
into a broader social movement not just
against increasing the age of retirement
but also against the continuing cost of
living crisis
the unions have characterized the
reforms as an assault on the country's
welfare system because I'm a teacher and
I think I'm going to be tired when I'm
64. so I'm not sure I'm able to teach
children
when I'm 64.
we youngsters are not only here for
ourselves and 30 years old my parents
are close to 60 and they will have to
work two or three more years
the pension reform still needs to go
through Parliament where macron has lost
his absolute majority so he's hoping to
get it passed with the support of
conservatives Bernard Smith Al Jazeera
Paris